so I was off yesterday thank you so much  everyone for let me have the day off was  for Ronan's birthday he turned the Levin  little road dog there he is he's so cute  isn't he  and then picture with his father Eric  and that was over the summer and then we  had the party at Chelsea Piers of  Bowlmor Lane and yeah but you would have  been fitting perfectly in size so we had  a laugh at that time bowling arcade  games a red velvet cupcakes  of course pigs in a blanket my favorite  that's us they're having a fabulous time  and then there's a little video here  there's the Road Dogg killing it with  the Titans without a touchdown Wow  baby's got wheels the kids frustrated  he's half down yep there we go  so he's um it's flag football so please  don't write in